Ryan Reynolds promoting Deadpool to all
over the world they stopped by the South
Korean show king of masked singer where
people go on in disguise and sing a song
Ryan dressed up as a unicorn to sing
tomorrow from Annie what do you think of
his pipes and yes this is Ryan Dulin
dance
where's the way that
[Music]
let's pray
[Music]
I just stick out my chin
and
about tomorrow
tomorrow
come on
[Music]
Oh
[Laughter]
now save your thoughts just for a second
we're gonna get to Iraq some people are
commenting yeah here's how they didn't
know that was Ryan underneath that mask
so here's how the audience reacted when
Ryan revealed himself
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hello everybody
I'm so sorry about that song our lease
is not bad tarah says sounds good
Alicia says OMG he's hilarious his voice
is bad yeah a couple of those notes work
too bad they weren't too bad in the
words of double J our famous floor
director what great promotion for
Deadpool it's like they're doing a
phenomenal job they're doing things
unconventionally which is what you have
to do to break through the noise and
it'd be more than than just promoting a
movie right look at us talking about it
he's had got what now three minutes of
our Facebook live precious time yeah you
know it's fantastic that Lisa is excited
much as those people are freaking out
though yeah I know how often that they
have celebrities in the big celebrity
like that underneath that was me as a
unicorn she just says he's an awful
[ __ ] career as a singer it wasn't bad